[Inaudible] a little
slowly
[inaudible].
Um, uh, I mean most when Leonore and Madeline speak,
especially about animals, if it's about, you know,
Heston Conine and then I get it more complicated than that. So.
And or the meaning the rabbit, that's the, one of the first words.
Swedish, because that's his little thing.
You can't live without the Kennan
special rabbit and she can't sleep without it. So it's, you know,
if we don't find Kennan, then it's, we're not going to go to bed that night.
Walked through Chelsea and she dropped it. We got home.
We realized that it wasn't,
that I spent two hours came back and forth across the streets.
I thought the they're turning the dustbin.
I was looking in dustbins people thought I was crazy, but I had to find out.
Terrible. And it's just, it's just clean and it doesn't go to name. It's just,
just, can you just come in? Do you,
do you sing lullabies?
Oh yes. All the time. Yeah.
What to do?
Yes, but I was so surprised that he didn't know that the blink, well,
you have it in Sweden. There you go. Hi, of course, Norwegians,
you know.
[Inaudible].
It was nice.
Probably we haven't seen the oil as well.
I'm going to get lots of problems because
this is your lucky day in a way, because we have an inter speaking guests here,
so we need to do this in England.
Um, tell me, can you, uh,
can you recognize the fact that people get nervous around you
when you, when you went through a room as a, as a Royal person, can you,
can you sense that the people get sort of.
Good, you know, sometimes, but I try to, you know,
smile and say hi and bring it back. That it's not, you know,
I'm just a normal person.
When she walks in the room. So.
[Inaudible] in the beginning, it must've been sort of awkward. I mean,
coming into this very special family, uh,
being a civilian, uh, I mean,
it must be didn't you feel sort of,
uh, I mean, yeah.
I think I would.
Be nervous meeting King and the queen for the first time.
Yeah, for sure. For sure. But you know what, in each of those circumstances,
they happened in unexpected way, so I wasn't fully prepared.
And so that took the edge off. Um, but, uh,
there's no how to book. There's no guide. There's no nothing.
So you have to learn a little bit on, on the flow, but for sure,
you definitely a little nervous. Huh?
How do you, if you, if you talk to the King, uh, your father-in-law,
how do you address him Giza?
You know, so yeah. She's mom. Yeah.
How did you meet, how did you get princess? How did she meet you?
Tell me if you don't want it every day.
Through mutual friends in New York.
And we were basically living in a way kind of parallel lives. You know,
I kind of saw something that she didn't see something.
No.
We, there was always chemistry. Laughter sense of humor.
That's really the bond that I think most couples that have to
kind of, you know,
endure a long time or through some kind of focus or nervous tension,
that sense of humor to take everything a little bit with a pinch of salt that
helps.
You make me laugh everyday
[inaudible] video. It was so beautiful your life and you guys, it was so nice.
Meeting her for the first time. You were quite sure quite early. I mean,
what did, what did you see?
You know, I saw,
I think in a way I think I read people well,
that's part of my jobs, what I've done. And with Madeline, you know, you,
you see that big smile, you see those eyes and she's very outgoing.
She's very honest, she's very forthcoming and sweet and welcoming.
And she immediately cause people, as you say, nervous around her and so forth.
And she's a spells that I necessarily wasn't nervous because we met in a private
setting. And um, but yet you just see that gregariousness and it's,
it's a wonderful thing. So, you know.
What did you say was Chris? Well, absolutely.
The sense of humor and you know, of course
[inaudible], Chris is a very, very, um, thoughtful person. He's very,
very generous and you know, he's, he's a true gentleman and um,
yeah, how's it. How's he changed him? Yes, absolutely.
Um, I feel, he felt, he makes me feel very safe and uh,
I think, um, we are a good team together.
We like kind of the same things and it's quite easy.
Have you changed it? I don't know for sure.
For sure.
[inaudible].
I'm gonna, I'm gonna ask my boyfriend that tonight.
[Inaudible] we all tried to change each other a bit. Don't we? I mean,
perhaps the clothes, the style, the something that.
Clothes, the style that I can't touch him. Hey, I see something. No, no, no, no,
this is, this is who I am. And that's what I like about Chris.
He's very much about, you know, this is me, I'm Christian Neil, and you know,
I'm not going to change. And I love that.
How have you, have you been changed by a boyfriend since so fairy tale a lot,
by the way?
No, no, man. You know,
my boyfriend's a bit older than we're quite a bit older than me.
And actually I felt like for the first time in my life so far,
um,
that that's why our relationship works so much is because he already is who is
going to be, but whereas anyone else I've ever been with isn't quite there yet,
so they're always changing a lot. Right. Um,
so I think the key to our success is that obviously we love each other,
but I think our age group actually really works for me and my boyfriend,
but yeah, I've changed loads, but I think for the better it's,
it's amazing being a real team rather than being very separate.
And when you argue rather than splitting up actually overcoming stuff,
it makes you more powerful and that's so true.
And especially now when you have children, it's, it's really being a team.
You really have to be strong together. Yeah.
You, you you're quite different people, aren't you? I mean.
Yes and no. I would say, uh,
I'm definitely the one who's maybe a little bit more calmer and you can
sometimes, you know, Chris is a very emotional guy.
[Inaudible] the Irish, you know, there's obviously [inaudible] so you,
you're more, more temperamental more. Absolutely.
So, so how the whole time,
how do you deal with that? I mean, when he's in one of his mood.
Well, you know, the one who deals best for is actually a or she just,
she just looks at him and say, hi.
Hi, just softens you in a second. Who's the most romantic of you?
You are. Yeah.
[inaudible] in, in, in, in New York, in, in Stockholm.
And now you live here in London, um, uh, w and you have two kids,
uh, and, um, so a lot has happened more or less say since you met,
uh, describe your, your life here in London, how is it?
Do you live in a house or do you live in a flat or a w what kind of life is it?
We, you know, we live in a very normal life right now.
I'm a full-time mom right now.
And I enjoy spending most of my time with, with our little kids.
And, um, I mean, Chris, you work a lot, but when you're home,
we try to do fun things together. And the weekends, we try to, you know,
go to this Sue, or we go to the local market and we find some nice, you know,
local vegetables.
I got a feeling. It might be he's pointing at him.
[inaudible] can you cut? No, actually,
I, I have to admit that I probably had never cooked a real meal for
Chris. I'm a terrible housewife. Tell it.
If you, if you had to cook something, what could that be?
Swedish meatballs.
[inaudible] maybe we should get a little less than going on,
but I'm the first one to sign up first and say, is it all right then English?
[inaudible] no, for sure. I will jump on that.
And I think Chris will be very happy if I do now, but Chris, I must say he's,
he's a very good chef. So, you know, I feel,
I don't even want to go into the kitchen because he's kind of, this is my area,
you know, you say, I tried to say, you know, darling,
did you need any help? I can chop, no, no, no. You just make a mess.
And he's very good chef, you know?
So, so what's your, what's your, uh, signature dish, if you, if you,
yeah. If you want to impress them.
Yeah. Yeah. I think, um,
we liked like in the winter we like making like big soups,
like a ribollita or a minestrone, you know,
your minestrone recipe is always my default guide. Thank you very much.
Absolutely. But, you know, as we say, we go to the market, you,
I kind of grew up sometimes in, in, in, in, in the holidays, in Italy and my,
my father's mother came from Sicily and there it's, it's, it's, you know,
you let the ingredients speak for themselves, you know,
and you try not to temper with them. So you, you know,
the way I kind of look at it is what you find guides you to what you're going to
cook. And if you find a great chicken, you find a great bit of edge.
You let you just let them tell you what you're going to cook.
And you just dictate it from that way. So,
but I like making different things different.
Do you remember the first meal you made here? That, that I cooked for her? Yeah.
Maybe my alley. All your spaghetti.
I think that's, you're kind of transpired to get all the questions. Very simple.
Isn't it.
Teeny, it's so simple, but you got to get it so right. To make it work.
So tell me about, uh, Leonore and Nicholas, uh,
because we don't know them yet. Uh, and, um,
you've just started to know them because they're very, very young, uh,
can see their personality already.
Yes, I sing it. I mean, especially with Leonor, she, um, you know,
it's kind of funny because she, her name is actually,
it means sunlight or sunshine. And, and I must say since the day she was born,
she's always had a smile on her face. She always, you know,
every day she makes us laugh and she's, she's really a fun little character.
She's wild, she's everywhere, but you know.
You are.
And the worst part about it is she already knows that she has her father wrapped
around her finger. So she's got it. Nicholas is,
is, is a, is a gentle soul. He he's had a tough time. As of late,
he had a little tummy bug, then he had fever and he's got a bit of a cough. So,
but even, so you come up to him and he looks at you and then you smile.
And then he smiles and it's all very gentle and very sweet.
She's more outgoing than he is, but you know, he's only six months.
So we'll see.
[Inaudible] are they like mini use, but just the opposite in a way.
That's a good question. I don't know. I don't know.
I think it's a good blend of each, for sure.
There's lots of attributes from each of us in both of them. So.
I can definitely see some positively annoyed in me, you know, kind of, yeah,
for sure. I was quite outgoing when I was a kid, I think, and, and, you know,
stubborn as well. And she's.
Well, you wait till they get older and you're arguing with them.
And the bit that they're beating you, it is the bit that's you.
Just a minute faster than me.
And also you become your own parents. I mean, slowly you become, you have, you,
have you noticed that, that you become like your own mother and you
kind of models out there and mother was.
Um, that's a good question. I don't know. Really. Um,
I think so in some way. Yeah, I think so. And I want, you know,
for me, uh, I feel that my, my parents there were so loving and, you know,
the most generous people I know, uh, but you know,
they were away a lot when we were kids, uh, due to their, you know,
obligation as a queen King and queen. And, um, so I, I feel that,
that I really want to give my full time right now with my kids,
because that's the part that I, that I miss a little bit. Um, and,
but otherwise, yeah.
And is that a generational thing? Is that, is that because that was the time?
Yeah.
I think so. Absolutely. I think our generation,
we are much more hands-on with the kids, especially the fathers. Um,
I think, you know, much more hands-on, I mean, you, you change,
I don't know how many diapers you change.
Remind me.
But yeah, but Madeline and, and, and, and Victoria as well, um, are,
if I may say born mothers, I mean,
it's incredible to watch them with their kids because it's,
it's just so natural and I can see it in cut it up as well,
because when he's with either ISTA, Leonora, you know, he,
he just is on the floor and he's playing and wrestling with them.
And so all three really are,
are so warm and kind with the kids that is, is, is,
it's an amazing thing to see it in action.
You, you were both, uh, where you are both, uh, the youngest. I mean, you,
you grew up with four sisters, uh, sorry, five sisters.
Um, so I mean, you being the youngest, they,
they had you in the trolley and just.
No, I looked like Jagger when I was young, I had this like long hair.
I had these like, always these hand-me-down coats,
which was bizarre because I had to kind of like,
and then they button the wrong way around. And it was all very strange,
but of course, looking back in hindsight, well, my mother, they, yeah.
And looking back, and it was like, you know, late seventies, early eighties,
now it looks so cool at that point. It was horrendous. But, you know, um,
it was a wonderful thing growing up with a lot of sisters because they really,
I think guide you and I'm, you know, I mean,
I think if women could rule the world,
the world would be in a lot better place than it is today. So, uh
[inaudible] and so I think that, you know,
having been with a lot of strong women in my life that that's only done any
positives.
I think so. Um, and, um,
are you shaped by being the, the, the, I mean the little sister,
do you think that has shaped who you are?
Yes. That's no families I'm sure. Um, you know, having, you know, my,
my sister because of parents were gone quite a lot, you know, make my sister,
she really took on that role of being the oldest sister. She,
she taught us a lot of things early stage,
and she always came up with fun plays. And my brother,
he was kind of in between these strong sisters. So,
which usually that happens with the middle child.
Yeah. And you're still very close with your brothers.
And like when you mentioned the stele and my sister,
it's so much fun nowadays, you know, when we spend our summer in, uh,
in an Island called Irlen in South part of Sweden,
and it was so much fun this summer too, to see that, you know, my sister and I,
we were doing the same things that we've always done when we were kids,
but now with our two daughters and, you know, we,
we start off the day and we would go and we pick the eggs from the chickens and
they would go to the, you know,
strawberry land and we'd some strawberries and then we'd go riding and,
and now we're doing with our daughters. And it's it really fun.
You, you, you, uh, you grew up in the limelight, uh, and,
um, I don't know what, what's your memories like, uh,
from that, I mean, being a child, uh, and so much,
uh, watched by anyone, every move move you made, was that a,
is that a positive memory or is it a tough memory for you?
You know, I was poor. My parents always got a headache when we were, you know,
having, you know,
family photos or something like that because I always run off and I was always
hiding and they always had to drag me there and I was screaming and I never
really want to be a part of it. And, um, you know, one,
one could sing that I've had this all my life. And, um,
one was thinking, what would maybe expect that I would be used to that by now,
uh, to be comfortable, you know,
in front of people or with photographers or journalists asking you a question,
but I'm really not. I'm I'm, I think in the end of the day, I'm,
I'm quite shy. And, um,
I don't like being in the center of attention, but, you know, as,
as an official person, as I am,
I know that this is something I have to deal with and, um,
I'm struggling with it. I'm working on it. And I'm here today.
[Inaudible] in what way, when you read about her,
when you've been criticism more?
Oh, absolutely. Sure. Of course. I'm her husband. So, you know, for me,
I'm very protective and, uh,
I know also that the people writing things, you know,
don't know who we are, you know, they've never met us. We might pretend they do,
but they've never spent time with us. They've never hung out with us.
So they may say things that kind of justify their own
means, but aren't really, you know, true. And you, you,
you get a thicker skin over time, you learn it and you, you,
you get to deal with it, but it's always a little painful for sure.
You'll have to find a balance because I mean, as we all know,
media is important and, uh, and, uh,
finding a balance.
And of course it saddens me sometimes when media might think that I'm
arrogant or, you know, because I'm not answering their questions, but it's,
that's really not, that's really not the case. It's not who I am. And,
and of course that, that upsets me sometimes. Um, but,
um, yeah, we.
Did. Did it ever happen that you thought, Oh, I wish she was not a princess.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Because, you know,
there were times when, you know, it's, it's interesting, um,
in England, in this country and, and, and kind of the Anglo-Saxon model,
we take privacy as a sacrosanct. You know,
it is God given right to certain things in one's life, private, um,
and you know,
it's not better or worse than a Scandinavian model where everything is very much
transparent and shared. It's very different. And in, in hindsight,
I was not aware of that and I was not prepared for that in a way.
So at some point I would have been like, Ooh, I love the skull.
And they fell in love with the skull. And I have to now, you know,
very much adapt my entire life towards who I fell in love with.
And there were times of course, when it wasn't so comfortable that you said, Oh,
I wish I didn't have to do this. They are little minute times. And you know,
it doesn't matter.
You, you have declined Royal privileges. I mean,
you ha you haven't got the title. Uh, have you ever considered the same?
You know, I feel that like, Chris, would,
you said in that if I can, through my title, you know,
point on important issues that I really think it's important
that we talk about, you know, for example, children's rights. Um, I will,
you know, I happily want to do that and if I can make a difference by just,
you know, raising the awareness about sexual abuse of children,
this is something we need to talk about. It's so important. And then I'm, I'm,
I'm proud of being a princess.
This is, this is, uh,
your mother's foundation that you now work with. Uh,
it's called childhood. Um, tell me,
w I mean, you've been involved in a lot of projects. Um,
what, what has made the strongest personal impression on you?
Oh, that's a tough question. Um, you know, w with childhood, um, and the,
for those of you who don't know, it's, um, it's about the,
we support the most vulnerable children as three children, children,
and lives in alternative care, uh, families at risk. And of course,
children has been sexually abused. And, you know, my mom,
when she founded Charlotte, uh, she found that she saw the,
nobody talked about this group of kids. It was,
it was so taboo and people didn't know really how to talk about it.
And I think it's still difficult for people. I noticed that some,
you know, they tune off a little bit when I start talking about it. But, um,
again, it's so important that we do address this problem,
because there are millions,
I think it's over 200 million of children out there who are being sexually
abused. And, um, you know,
only in the U S I think one of 10 children are being
abused before the,
at T 85% of these kids are 11 years or younger.
So for me,
knowing that there's so many kids out there who are sexually abused and
exploited,
and it makes me even more determined that we have to do something about it,
and we can do.
[Inaudible].
The role of a modern princess, uh, um, um, the,
the press criticizing, you will interpret it differently.
They would interpret that you should also be available to,
to the brands to cut more readers. Yes, that's exactly.
No, I, and I understand it. And, um, I'm, I,
I absolutely think I should do. I can do both. And I see myself, you know,
now living here in England, um, I feel that I could do much,
much more for Sweden abroad. Uh, I can promote, you know,
Swedish companies, a huge market here in, in UK. And I think we are,
we're 50,000 suites living in London.
So there are a lot of things I can do here.
So what you're saying, you could do more.
Absolutely. She's being a full-time mom. That's better. There'd been a princess,
in my opinion.
[Inaudible] do you have any, even though you haven't got a title,
do you have any limitations as a business man in your business? I mean, you're,
you're a businessman, you're an investor. Do you, do you feel that your,
this role being her husband gives you some limitations?
It did in my previous job.
And that's part of the reason that a small part of the reason why I left that
job, because the, uh,
we were managing capital on behalf of clients and they
weren't comfortable in the, kind of the intrusion of, of, uh,
of the press into my life. Um,
and so now I've had to adapt what I do in so far that it's really
business to business type of, um, um, business.
And therefore you're speaking to large institutions, they're multinationals,
um, outside of certain geographic markets. Um,
they don't know who I am at all. So, you know, it, it doesn't really come into,
I don't think it's really ever come up in,
in what I've been doing for the last three or four years, um,
who I am or what I do. So that, that's the plus side of it.
W w what is it you do really? I mean, you know.
That's a good question.
So I sat behind four computer screens for like 20 years of my life.
I was just trading. And while I was okay at what I did,
and I liked what I did, and I enjoyed it,
it was time for me to not do that anymore.
And so I basically spent a lot of my time focusing on two industries,
MoMA's payment processing, and one was energy.
And now I've identified two opportunities in those two industries
that I am trying to explain and, and make some business from. Uh,
these are long-term contracts dealing with very, very big companies.
And so, uh, it takes time to end them.
It's very frustrating sometimes because you're, you, you know,
you have a solution that would really fix problems that they have. Um,
but you know, trying to make a Titanic move takes time.
Okay. Um, before, before we wrap up tonight,
I liked what I did now. Sorry. I really, that was, that was,
that was a couple of things, because you're here, you had not,
not the problem, but you have one here, down there. She was like,
[inaudible],
let's talk about the future because many people wonder what's going to happen.
Uh, I mean, how long are you staying in England? You you've been as I living in,
in, in New York, in, in Stockholm for, for a bit. And, uh, now in London,
are you, are you staying here forever or what's the plan?
I don't know. I really, we're looking at each other. Um, you know,
right now it's a very good place for us to be, uh, because of Chris,
your business. Uh, and, you know, I find London,
it's a perfect place because it's, it's close to home, uh,
to my family. And then my friend. So it's easy for me to pop over whenever. Um,
New York was a little bit far away. I'm sure you've maybe felt the same thing,
having family here. Uh, so.
Do you, do you have a, do you have a, like a Scandinavian home here,
or do you have, have you gone totally British with the, you know,
carpet on the bathroom floor and everything?
That's the thing I don't really understand.
We like white clean surfaces.
It's probably thanks to our care anyway. Really.
It probably was all carpets in the eighties.
No, I think we have a mix day. Yeah.
Leonora is, is starting school when she's six years old, what,
what do you think? I mean, what should be, do, do you have.
Six years is a, is four years from now. So, you know, what we do is we,
we, we lay out different, you know,
kind of alternative options and we preregistered and do all the things that one
has to do and had spreadsheets come out. I mean, in this country, I mean,
it's incredible, you know, I've had, I've had schools say, no,
you're on the wait list because you should have phone 24 hours after birth,
you know?
Well, when I was pregnant, I should have done it. But when I had it,
when I was pregnant, bearing in mind,
the artists went to the local school around the corner is revelation to me,
all that, not putting their names, then I've even got a name.
Next month.
You know, we, we, what we've done is we've said, look, let's,
let's consider every eventuality plan accordingly and take it as,
as it comes. Yeah.
I think it was a portrait also, see, you know, what's,
what's best for the kids and the end of the day and, and take it from there.
Yeah.
Uh, near future Christmas coming up. Uh, how do you plan to celebrate Christmas?
We are actually celebrating Christmas here with Chris family.
I see. When stocking and everything, or do you do stockings? I don't know.
We're weird in our family. We,
we celebrate on the 24th because my mother and the Germanic side of us.
So we actually do it more kind of in a German style. Um,
so we don't have stockings. We have Christmas trees and things like this,
but obviously, but we celebrate on the 24th and, um,
but we're going to be in Sweden for most of December. And then we come back.
I'm sure we will enjoy a little bit of a Swedish. You called the class.
Did you have a youth board? Do you know where that is? You.
Know, smokers? I'm sure
food is something that's very difficult. Lots of people,
lots of [inaudible] sausages and lots of the herrings.
And what else do we have that
little bit weirder things going on?
I think we're spending it here. I'm in England and yeah, Turkey.
I make a really good Brussels sprout Baton because I hate Brussels sprouts.
Yeah. It's for the double cream though. Jamie
[inaudible] understanding where I can eat 'em um, and I tend to make, um,
like a blueberry sort of pie thing. So yeah.
Large chocolate for like 16 people in the Turkey didn't fit in the oven.
I'd sit with your back against the oven. It was a nightmare.
[Inaudible] yes. Yes. Thank you so much for being a real pleasure to meet you.
[inaudible].